[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIYA NAGORNA:
My name is Maria,
and I am a technical program
manager here at Google.
And with me is Krishna, who
does product management.
We both work on a
developer platform
called Actions on Google.
And in this session,
we'll discuss
how you can create actions for
your existing Android apps.
And then we'll
talk about how you
can leverage those actions
to build deeper integrations
with the Google Assistant
so that you can reach
more users on your devices.
KRISHNA KUMAR: Great.
Everybody is here bright and
energetic in the morning?
All right.
Let's have a quick
show of hands first.
How many of you attended the
App Action session on Tuesday?
All right.
I see a few hands.
So today, we are going
to talk a little bit
about how you can enable
actions on your Android apps
and how you can
make them surface
across various touchpoints
on the Android platform.
If that sounds interesting, we
had this very detailed session
two days ago, which had a lot
of code samples, et cetera.
So definitely I'd request you
to take a look at those code
samples and that video.
And we also have an
office hours immediately
after that, so you can come
and ask us for questions.
So we're going to provide a
quick recap on App Actions
and Android apps.
Then we're going to talk
a little bit about how
you as Android developers
can use the same development
mechanism that you
use for App Actions
to basically create
conversational actions to take
your services to the plethora
of new smart devices coming out.
So that's the agenda for today.
But let's start with,
what are actions?
Our devices are our
portal to the world.
We do everything with them.
We watch videos.
We consume content.
We navigate the world
using our devices.
And there are two primary
critical user needs
for how people use devices.
One is they actually
consume content.
And that includes everything
from listening to music
to watching videos to getting
your best recipes, et cetera.
The other is we use our
devices to get things done.
The world has changed.
Like, you are no more
running back to your desktop
to find maps or to book a
ticket or to purchase something
online.
You use your device.
It's our single
portal to the world.
However, there are something
like 2 million Android apps
out there.
And there's probably several
hundred millions of websites.
That's awesome.
That gives the users enormous
choice and possibilities.
But that can also be a
little bit overwhelming.
Just try thinking
immediately of,
like, which app do I immediately
use to find the best fish
taco in San Diego.
There's just a lot
of apps out there.
And for you, as
a developer, it's
even more problematic
because it causes problems
of discovery and re-engagement.
So there was a statistic in
Android Authority in March 2016
that 77% of users don't
use the app within three
days of installation.
Man, that's crazy.
And that number goes up
to 90% within a month.
So in this very
crowded space, it's
hard to get this re-engagement.
And you're developing all
these cool new features.
But even though the user
might have installed your app,
they just don't know
what's going on.
They don't know what are the
new capabilities of the app.
So we are providing a sneak peek
on what we call app actions.
Dave Burke mentioned
this in the consumer
keynote today, or a
couple of days ago.
And App Actions is a way for
you, as Android developers,
to surface the
capabilities of your app
and bring that up so
that Google can surface
your capabilities, your
actions, and your content
across many different touch
points across the Android
platform.
As the Android platform
evolves to an AI first world,
we are moving from just
predicting the next app
to predicting the next action
that a user might take.
And we will surface the
capabilities of your app
at just the right
moment, either based
on the user context,
the user routine,
or based on things
like the user query.
So this gives you instant
increase in both reach
and re-engagement.
But how does this all work?
How does this show up
in the Android platform?
Let's start with
Google Assistant, which
everybody is interested in.
With App Actions, you can
basically get your Android apps
to have a basic integration
and shortcut with a Google
Assistant for
task-based queries.
So in this particular
scenario, the user
is asked something
like, manage my budget.
And that immediately
brings up the Mint app
straight to the budget page.
How is this done?
It is because the Mint
app, in this example,
has registered for an
intent of budget management
in this file called actions.xml.
And we'll go through a lot
more in detail of how exactly
you register for intents.
This also works for
content-based queries.
So I have asked, what is
Lady Gaga's real name.
And believe it or not, I
actually didn't know till now.
Stefani, OK.
We now try to
understand and predict,
what is the next follow-on
action that the user might do?
If I'm basically
searching for Lady Gaga,
I think it's a
natural conclusion
that I might want to
listen to her latest album
or watch a video or buy
tickets for her concerts.
So we try to predict
the next action
and show that as suggestion
chips down on the bottom.
Clicking on any of
those suggestion
chips immediately opens
the appropriate Android app
straight to the Lady Gaga page.
Just think about what a good--
how many steps you
are still saving here.
You're not rummaging
through your app browser
to find out the
app, then you're not
typing Lady Gaga
there again, and then
you're not trying
to find out what.
All of this happens magically
so that it just surfaces up
across the Android platform.
We're also exploring
how we can actually
surface apps that you use a
lot directly in Google search.
So I use Fandango
to book tickets.
So if I type a movie
like "Avengers,"
it shows me various
suggestion chips for Fandango
right at the bottom.
So clicking on any of
those suggestion chips
will basically take me directly
into Fandango, where I can
immediately purchase a ticket.
As Android evolves,
last year, in Android O,
we brought up this concept
of predicting the next app
that you might use, that is
the top row that you see there.
This actually had a 60%
prediction accuracy rate
and was wildly successful.
Now what you're
doing is actually
moving from predicting
the next app
to predicting the next
action that you might do.
So in this blue
highlighted column there,
you see basically
two suggestions.
And these are two suggestions
that happen in my phone
at around 5:00 to
5:30 in the evening.
And this is based on
the frequency of usage
for various tasks
and actions I do.
So here's my routine.
At 5 o'clock, I call my spouse--
Mona, wife-- and
then I argue with her
as to who has to
pick up the kids.
I inevitably lose that argument.
And then I navigate to my kids'
school to pick up the kids.
So those two suggestions, those
two actions happen very often.
And therefore it is
shown up as suggestions.
Now, these suggestions are
contextual and routine-based.
So, for example, if you
live in San Francisco
and you use a transit app
at the transit station,
when you approach
the transit station,
it knows that particular context
and it will automatically
show a suggestion
for the transit app.
And those are the
types of predictions
that we can do based on many
different inputs of context
and routines.
We're also directly working
with App Actions and things
like Smart Select.
So in an email or
in the browser,
if I choose a piece
of text, what happens
is that Smart Text Selection,
uses machine learning
to predict the full entity.
So if I click on floor in
this particular example,
it basically selects the
whole Floor and Water,
which is a restaurant,
and shows me
the action for reserving
a table using OpenTable.
Now, when I click on
OpenTable, it immediately
takes me to the
OpenTable's Floor and Water
page, where basically I can
book the table immediately.
So these are all ways in
which App Actions surface
across many different
places for the apps
that you have installed on
your device, which thus leads
to more re-engagement
because we understand
the type of capabilities
that your apps have
and continue to expand upon.
But what about apps
which are not installed?
App Actions also shows up
on the Play Store page.
In the Play Store page, if
I type in query "Lady Gaga,"
you know, "flight
tickets," it shows
me various actions
that apps have,
both for apps that are installed
on my device and apps which
are not installed.
This allows for great
discovery, because you actually
understand the capabilities
of the apps that can actually
directly act upon the
query that you provided.
In this case, of Lady
Gaga, you get a bunch
of suggestions for apps
which can do everything
from play music to show lyrics.
And if that particular show
lyrics app is not installed,
when I click on it
it will basically
give me the option
to install that app,
and then it will
directly take me
to the deep link for Lady Gaga.
Now, App Actions is
very interesting.
This is part of the larger
actions on Google Framework.
So we have created a common
development mechanism,
which includes built-in intents,
which is how you actually show
the capabilities of your app.
That is the API to show the
capabilities of your app.
And that same built-in
intent mechanism
can be used for App Actions,
conversational actions,
vertical programs, and
so on and so forth.
You have created
a foundation layer
that enables you
to create actions
across multiple
platforms, operating
systems, and surfaces.
We'll go a lot more into that.
MARIYA NAGORNA: Great.
So those were some
really cool examples
of how the actions
of your Android app
can be featured in suggestions
across the Android surfaces.
Now let's take a look at some
of the steps of creating app
actions to achieve just that.
So first, using tools you're
all familiar with for building
and publishing Android apps--
namely the Android studio and
the Play Developer console--
you'll create an
actions.xml file.
And this is the central
place for all of the actions
that your Android
app can support.
There are two key
pieces of information
that you'll need her
provide for each action.
And that is the intent
and the fulfillment,
which describes the what
and the how of your actions.
So let's dive deeper into
some of these concepts,
and we'll start with built-in
intents, which is how you
indicate what your action does.
My team at Google has
built and published
a catalog of built-in intents,
and as Krishna mentioned,
this is one of the core
foundational elements
of app actions.
If you think about the way
users ask for information,
there's a myriad of
linguistic variations
that they can use to
construct their query.
So for example, they can
say calming activities,
or they can say
breathing exercises
to relax about my presentation.
Or they can ask for a 10-minute
meditation techniques.
All of these queries,
they indicate
that the user would
like to de-stress,
or they'd like to calm down.
So we've designed,
built-in intents
in such a way that
they abstract away
all of the natural
linguistic variations,
and we pass on only the relevant
information to your application
from the user's query
using parameters.
And so to give Google a
deep understanding of what
your Android app can
do, what you need to do
is register for the
relevant built-in intents
that are relevant to
your app, and this
will help Google show
the right actions
to users at the right time.
Here are some of the intents
that we're working on now.
And the ones that have
a star next to them
are available for developers
to try out today and preview.
And throughout the
remainder of the year,
we'll be continuously extending
this catalog to cover as many
of your use cases as we can.
And if you have an Android
app where we're not
covering the use case currently,
please do give us feedback.
We take it very
seriously, and we'll
show you how to do that
at the end of this talk.
Now let's talk
about fulfillment,
which describes how a user
would invoke a specific action
within your app.
So when users express an
action that they'd like
to accomplish-- a task or
an intent that they have--
you can help them fulfill that
action by specifying deep links
into your Android apps.
So in your actions.xml,
you can define
the mapping between the built-in
intents and the deep link URL.
And this will enable Google
to show the right content
to your users from
your Android app
and deep link them directly
into the experience
that they seek in
that specific moment.
So we have two models
for fulfillment.
In the first model, which
is the URL template model,
we can start the
deep link URL based
on the user's query parameters.
And your actions.xml
will tell us
how to map the parameters
from the built-in intent
to the URL parameters.
And this model is ideal
for action-centric apps
with deep link APIs.
And in the content-driven model,
we discover the fulfillment URL
through your web content
or the structured data
that you give us.
And then based on
the user's query,
we find the relevant
content and then use
your actions.xml to
connect the content
to the appropriate intent.
So let's see an example
of how this would work,
and we'll use the
Coursera Android app,
and we'll show you
how they registered
for the action of TAKE_COURSE.
And the reason that
they want to do this
is so that when a user
comes to the Android
and they want to know
information about courses
or education, we can ensure
that the Coursera app is
shown to them as a suggestion.
And for this demo,
we'll also show you
how the suggestion will show
up on the Google Assistant.
So for the built-in
intent, we created one,
and it's called TAKE_COURSE,
and it takes a single parameter
of the type course.
And this is the
parameter that if you
were to implement-- to register
for this particular intent,
you would need to handle
it from the user's query.
And so for example, the user
might say, take a machine
learning course with
Coursera, and the assistant
will know that machine learning
is of type course.name.
Or, if they ask for find data
science courses on Coursera,
the assistant will match
the data science parameter
to the correct type.
Of course, it named that
about, because that's
what the course is about.
Now you might wonder
how does Google exactly
know this particular mapping?
So in Coursera's
case, each course page
is annotated with
schema.org markup,
and there is a page
called Machine Learning,
and it is associated
with a specific URL.
So this is an example of the
content-based fulfillment
that we talked about a
couple of slides back.
And so to bring these
two things together--
we have our actions XML, and we
tie these two things together
in a really simple way.
So first, you register for the
built-in intent of TAKE_COURSE,
and then we take the
course parameter,
and map it to the main web page
URL for Coursera for learning.
And that's it.
It is that simple.
So let's now see how this
app action will show up
on my Pixel device
in the Assistant.
So lets go to the Assistant.
And we'll ask it about
machine learning.
Machine learning.
Great.
So what we see here is a basic
card about machine learning
from the Assistant, but now
below in the suggestions,
we see the TAKE_COURSE
action that we just created,
and we know that it's from
Coursera because of the Apps
icon.
Now let's see what happens
when I tap into it.
Awesome.
So it takes me to
the Coursera app,
directly into the Machine
Learning course page
that I just asked about.
And from here, I can
do things like enroll,
and I can also explore
the rest of my app.
So as the user, that was
really [? refreshing ?]
about how quick and simple
that experience was for me.
In just two taps, I was
able to enroll for my course
right away.
And for Coursera, it was
also fairly simple, right?
Just by creating a
single actions.xml file,
Coursera can now get users
to discover and reengage
with their Android app
across multiple touch
points on the Android device.
But there's one caveat here.
This will only work
on Android devices.
Today, we know that users
are beginning to increasingly
turn to new device types to
accomplish their daily tasks.
And so in this next
part, we'll talk
about how you can
go beyond Android
and how you can reach
these users that
are using these new devices
that don't run the Android.
KRISHNA KUMAR: Thanks, Mariya.
That was very cool.
Just a single file--
actions.xml-- and you
can get your actions
surfacing up in various
touch points across operating
systems.
Works great for Android
devices, and you
can bring up the content and
capabilities of your app.
But what about all these
other devices which
are coming up in the market?
You cannot go to an electronic
store without seeing smart
speakers, smart TVs, smart
displays, smart whatever.
Right?
And all of these are
Google Assistant enabled,
but these are not Android
devices, or at least many
of them are not Android devices.
How do you, as a
service provider,
bring your services--
bring your functionality--
to all these new devices?
And first of all, as
an Android developer,
why should you even
care about that?
Let's talk a little
bit about that.
So, Google has been doing
a bunch of user research
on how people interact,
get information,
and get their tasks
done throughout the day.
And our research has shown
that the way people interact
to accomplish their
tasks throughout the day
are very different.
And the type of tasks that
they do is also very different.
For example, in the
morning when you're quickly
cooking breakfast and
you're in a rush to get out,
you might quickly catch up
on news, find the traffic,
find the weather, check your
calendar, and then rush out.
And when you're commuting, you
might be checking the news,
or listening to
music, navigating,
and that's very
different from when
you're at home in the evening--
relaxing, cooking,
dinner, or watching the TV
with your family and you want
to find out the latest buzz
Netflix show, right?
The types of devices
you use is different.
The types of information
that you want to get
is very different.
In the context that you're in--
you're relaxing on the couch,
or you're driving.
Those contexts are
also very different.
And increasingly,
users are starting
to use many different
types of devices.
When you're cooking breakfast--
when your hands are greasy,
you don't necessarily
want to pull off your phone--
your brand-new, spanking
new, costly phone.
And when you're
commuting, you might
want to get some information
on the latest score,
how does your day look like,
but your hands are busy.
Or at least you shouldn't
be using your Android phone
in those contexts.
When you are going
for a jog, you
might want to check
your calories,
or you might want to check
the steps that you've done.
But again, you may
not necessarily
be carrying out your phone.
And finally, when you're
in front of the TV
and want to get the
latest Netflix show,
the phone may not be
necessarily the best context.
Users are increasingly becoming
more sophisticated on how
they interact with
devices, and they
expect that the devices will
provide the right information
to them, as well as
help them accomplish
their tasks in the
most hassle-free,
and the most natural
way possible.
They don't want to
contort themselves
into trying to
use a device where
it's not right for that
particular context.
And Google Assistant
has been spending
a lot of time thinking of
these critical user journeys
and being there for the user
in all of these contexts.
Google Assistant
enables you to interact
with users in
completely new ways
using a combination of voice,
rich UI, cards UI, and many
of these inter-modal behaviors.
It enables you to create
fundamentally new experiences,
thus reaching and engaging
your users in a different way
for these different contexts.
And the Google Assistant is
now on across 500 million
plus devices.
Everything from phones, to
smart speakers, to smart TVs,
to smart displays
and headphones.
So that you can reach your
user in the right context,
in the right place that
where they are and so
that increases your breath
for options of your services
across all of these
different contexts.
Now, making a conversational
response interaction
seems complex, but we have built
a cutting-edge technology stack
to take away a lot
of that complexity.
We have built all
this natural language
processing-- individual voice
recognition, machine learning
algorithms for inflection, et
cetera, different voice types,
and using Google's core assets
in the Knowledge Graph identity
payments and put
together a technology
stack so that we can make it
easier for you as developers.
Can you imagine building
all of this infrastructure
by yourself for
every single app?
It's just not feasible.
So we have built this
technology stack,
and we invite you
to build upon--
on top of our technology
stack and focus
on building compelling new
experiences for your users.
Conversational
actions are, again,
part of the larger
Google framework.
You will use the
same intents Mariya
talked about the
built-in intents
that Mariya talked about
that you use for app actions
also for conversational actions.
And during the rest
of this session,
we will see some of the
foundational elements that
enable your Android
apps and services
to work more seamlessly with
your conversational actions.
But you're probably thinking
now, oh, man, this Google.
They're asking me to rebuild
my whole app for voice.
Come on.
OK, so I'm not asking you
to rebuild or replicate
your whole app.
I want to bring this concept
of a companion conversational
action.
A companion action is
basically providing
a snippet of information,
or helping the user complete
a specific task
that the user might
use of your service in
a different context.
The best way to think about
this is through an example.
Let us take the
case of GoalAlert.
GoalAlert is a pretty
popular soccer app,
which has rich information on
teams in Europe, league tables,
points, all of that good stuff.
Fantastic.
I use it every day
during the World Cup.
All right.
So what happens when I go to a
completely different context.
I'm driving to work
and I just want
to catch up with the
latest score as to what
happened yesterday.
Keep in mind, an Android
app such as this,
which is not part of
messaging or media
will not show full-screen
on Android Auto.
So how do you actually get
this information to the user
and extend that reach
to a new context?
So what GoalAlert has done is--
they found the piece
of their service,
such as check the
latest score, which
makes more sense for the user in
a completely different context,
and they have created a simple
conversational action, which
provides the response for what
are results of the Premier
League, or what happened
to that match yesterday,
or what are the scores?
So they created a rich
conversational plus UYRS
response, which can be used
across all Assistant devices.
Let's take another example--
Todoist.
Todoist, as everybody knows,
is a popular, to-do app.
It's a rich to-do app with
more than 10 million downloads.
It has all sorts of
detailed task information,
different ways you can
manipulate it, et cetera.
Great.
What do you do when
you're cooking breakfast,
and you just want to find what
tasks do I have due today?
Here again, Todoist has thought
through the critical user
journeys that their users
have and figured out
that what task do
I have due today is
a service which goes
across multiple contexts,
across multiple devices.
So they've created a
conversational action
to provide a single,
easy response to,
what do I have due today?
So as far as a developer
journey with actions
goes for building these
conversational actions, for app
actions, you're
familiar with this.
You're created an
Android APK, you're
going to add an actions.xml
file using Android Studio.
You will test it out
in Android Studio,
and you will publish it using
the standard Play console
mechanisms for publishing
your Android app.
Let's take that
for conversational.
For conversational,
you're going to, again,
use the same built-in
intent mechanism to build
conversational actions.
You will build simple
conversational actions
using dialogue flow,
which is a tool provided
by Actions on Google.
And you'll go to the Actions
on Google Actions console--
to manage, publish, your
conversational agent
and conversational action.
Let us see how all of this
works together from a high level
architecture perspective.
If I'm creating an
app, and let's say
this is Krishna's To-Do App.
It's a task-based app.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to put up a web server--
node.js or Apache or whatever--
connect it to a database
where all of my users'
to-do tasks are stored,
then I'm going to create an
Android app, which basically
talks to the web server
to get that user's
information provided back to my
app, which will render it based
on the UI design of my app.
The same concept works for
our friends down the street,
and it also works for
event-based interface
to your app.
When you you then go to
conversational agents, what
you're going to
do is you're going
to create a conversational
agent, which basically will
talk to your web server
using the same API, same
infrastructure that
you're provided.
What happens is
for a query of what
task do I have today, the
assistant will take care
of all of the lateral
language processing,
query understanding--
it understands what the
query is, and then in walks
your agent.
Your agent will then basically
understand that query,
and now your agent
has to actually do
a fulfillment for that query.
So to do the fulfillment, what
you're going to do, is you're
going to use a web
hook, which will
connect to the web
server on your back end,
and then provide the
response back to the user.
The key point here is
that you, as a developer,
are using the exact same
infrastructure, API, identity
mechanisms that you
already used for your apps,
to also provide a
conversational response for all
of Assistant enabled devices.
Now, let's talk
a little bit more
about this foundational layer.
Mariya explained a little
bit about built-in intents,
but we also provide a certain
set of foundational elements,
which basically lets
you create easy,
seamless interaction
between your Android apps,
and your conversational agents.
Let's, again, go back to
out Todoist, our to-do app,
and let's think a little
bit about account linking.
You probably as an
Android developer,
especially if you have some
sort of service back end,
have some form of an
account management system.
Todoist uses various
identity mechanism, including
Google as an identity.
And as a user, when I start
using Todoist on Android,
I can create my
identity using Google
or through some other
identity mechanisms.
When you go to the Assistant,
and when you set up
Todoist do for the first
time on your Assistant,
you will have to
link your Todoist
identity to the Assistant.
Once you do the
linking, you can use
your conversational response
across any Assistant-enabled
device without having to
log in into Todoist again.
The key point here is
that in Actions console,
you can link your accounts so
that things work seamlessly.
And with one step of account
linking for the user,
the user can use Todoist across
any Assistant-enabled device.
That was account linking.
Let us talk a little bit
about play, entitlements,
and seamless digital
subscriptions.
The interesting thing is that
both the Assistant and Android
uses this Google Play for
inventory and order management,
and entitlements management.
Because of the fact
that both of them
use the same Google Play
infrastructure, entitlements,
subscriptions, in-app
purchases work seamlessly
across both Assistant
and Android.
Let us take the case
of Economist Espresso.
"Economist" is a great
magazine, and they
have an app called
Economist Espresso, which
has a subscription feature to
get their premium articles.
I went and logged
into my Android app,
and paid the
subscription in Android.
Now, when I go to the Assistant
and use Economist Espresso,
I immediately get access to
all of their premium content,
because the Assistant also
knows that I have a premium
subscription to
Economist Espresso,
and hence I'm eligible for
all of the premium content.
And this works reverse, also.
You can purchase subscriptions
in the Assistant,
and it will work on
your Android app, also.
And the way this works,
again, can be done
and the Actions console.
The Assistant first will
check whether you have access
to these premium subscriptions.
You can then purchase content
using the same Inventory
and Order Management System.
And then your
premium subscriptions
work across the Assistant,
and, as mentioned,
also across Android.
So in all of these scenarios
about companion conversational
actions, these
developers-- what they did
is, they thought of this
very specific use case
and built a
conversational action.
So here are my principles
for building a companion
conversational action.
You're not just an app provider.
You are a service provider.
And as a service
provider, you want
to take your service,
your functionality,
to many new contexts.
So think beyond the app
and think of the service
that you're providing.
Also, what is the critical
user journey for your service?
Like, how do people actually
interact with your service?
In what context?
In what device?
And can you think of
new contexts and devices
in which your service actually
makes sense to the user?
And also, you're going to
expand the reach of your service
quite a bit, but please do
not think of just replicating
your whole app for voice.
You need to think of the
specific service that
makes sense for the user.
So my challenge to you is--
what are the compelling
new experiences
that you can create by
integrating with the Google
Assistant?
Please join these
number of providers
who have already
created an Android app,
but have also
expanded their reach
to a number of
Google-enabled devices
by building a
conversational agent.
MARIYA NAGORNA: Thanks, Krishna.
So that was a really
high-level overview
for how you can think
about companion actions
to your Android app.
How to really think
about the experience
that you can provide your users
for those times in their life
when their Android device
just might not be handy.
So there's two such times that
come to my mind right away.
First of which is while I'm
driving and my full attention
needs to be on the road,
and my Android device
is usually in my pocket.
And then the second
is while I'm cooking,
and my hands are usually
either busy or they're dirty,
and it's really
inconvenient to have
to keep going back and forth
between washing my hands,
unlocking my phone, reading
the recipe, making my food,
washing my hands, unlocking
my phone-- you get the idea,
right?
This is a normal
cooking process.
So I have two devices to
help me in these situations.
I have the Assistant
in my car, and I
have the Smart Display at home.
So I'd like to go back
to the Coursera example
that we introduced
earlier, and I'd
like to show you how
we helped them take
their app beyond Android so
that it could accompany me
throughout my day
with the situations
that I just described.
So we all know machine
learning is a pretty hot topic
right now.
And so as we saw earlier,
I did register for it
on for it on Coursera.
And I like to go through
my courses after work.
So I like to listen
to the course podcast
while I'm driving in my car,
and then when I get home,
I like to continue watching
the video for the course
that I started to
listen to in the car.
Now neither my car nor my smart
device at home run Android.
Both of these devices, they only
work with the Google Assistant.
And so let's see how we helped
build the Coursera companion
app that works on
the Google Assistant.
Here's the actions.xml
that we showed you earlier
where they registered for the
TAKE_COURSE built-in intent.
And now after their APK
was approved and published
in the Play Developer
console, there now
appeared an option
there to enhance actions
with actions on Google.
And clicking there lands us
in the Actions Console Project
Claiming Page.
Now, this console is
a really focused way
to develop and manage your
companion action for the Google
Assistant.
And we're very excited
because this week, we
announced a major
redesign of this console,
and it basically helps
you do three main things.
It first allows
you to configure,
set up the metadata
and the directory
listing information
for your companion app.
And then it allows you to manage
the development, the testing,
and the deployment process
in a very fine-grained way.
And then once your
action is published,
it gives you
analytics so that you
can track how your
action is doing out there
with real users
in the real world.
Now, there's a lot of
magic that happens here
during this project
claiming stage.
For example, we automatically
import most of the information
that you provided
in the actions.xml
to make it easier for you to
develop your companion app.
Now let's see with the Actions
console looks like for Coursera
after they've gone through
the claiming process.
So this is the Actions console.
And we can see that it's already
set up with the Coursera demo
app.
Let's look into this
Actions section.
And we see here the
TAKE_COURSE built-in intent
that we had in Android
was automatically
imported from
actions.xml when we went
through that claiming process.
And when we click
in, we'll hopefully
see some magical
information show up here.
There you go.
So we see all of
the triggering--
we see all of the
important information
that you would want to
know about this action.
So for example, the
triggering phrases up there,
these are sample
invocations that users
can use to invoke this
particular action.
And we see the
parameters, as well as
the fulfillment information
that you provided us
in your actions.xml, and
that was automatically
imported into here.
Now that we have this basic
wiring set up, what we can do
is we can create a rich response
using dialogue flow to cover
those two cases that
I described I wanted
to have earlier for Coursera.
So to listen to my course
podcast while I'm driving
and then to continue watching
my video when I get at home.
And to do that,
you would just add
the fulfillment of
conversational type here,
and this will land
us in dialogue flow
where you can specify the
details about the fulfillment.
Now, because we're a
bit short on time today,
I won't show you how you can
build fulfillment from scratch,
but there are a
few key components
that I'd like to walk
through so that you can see
how you do this for yourself.
So this is the dialogue flow
to, and this is the JavaScript
for our fulfillment code.
We see here that we first use
the TAKE_COURSE built-in intent
that we walked through
earlier, and then
we reference the
course parameter
to understand what is the name
of the course that is coming
in from the user's query.
We also created a function that
calls the back end Coursera
service to get the
details from the course
that the user is asking about.
And then when we get the
response, what we can do
is parse it.
And for this particular
example, we'll just
create a simple card that
shows us all of the course
information, and then we
use our media response API
to return the audio or
the video of the course
based on what device
I'm running on.
Now, one really amazing
thing about dialogue flow
is that it's simply integrated
with the Actions console.
It has a really deep
integration with that console.
And so this provides a really
nice development environment
where you can do
things like test
how this would work on
the Google Assistant
directly from this
UI, just by simply
clicking in this section.
So let's see how this
basic card that I just
showed you we created would
look like in the simulator.
So this is the
simulator, and we also
have a Test On
Device option so you
can test during your
process to see how
it would work on the device.
But for now, let's see how
this would work when we
invoke our Coursera demo app.
So we'll say, ask Coursera demo
to start my machine learning
course.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure,
here's the test version
of Coursera demo.
SPEAKER 1: Here's
more information
about machine learning.
Do you want to start the course?
MARIYA NAGORNA: Great.
So what we see here is the
card that we created, right?
So all of this description
information down here,
the title of the card,
this image, the suggestion
chips down there--
they were all specified
in the fulfillment code
that I showed you
in dialogue below.
So now let's say yes to
start the course podcast.
SPEAKER 1: Sure, here's your
course on machine learning.
SPEAKER 2: Our first
learning algorithm
will be linear aggression.
MARIYA NAGORNA: Great.
So this allows me to listen
to the course podcast
while I'm driving.
Now let's imagine that I
started doing that in my car,
and then when I get home, I want
to continue watching my video
on the Smart Display device.
So let's try it here
and hopefully it works.
OK, Google, continue my course.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sorry, I don't
know how to help with that yet.
But I'm trying to learn.
MARIYA NAGORNA: OK, Google.
Continue my course.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sorry, I don't
know how to help with that.
I'm still trying.
KRISHNA KUMAR: Third try.
MARIYA NAGORNA: OK Google,
continue my course.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
let's get Coursera.
SPEAKER 1: Welcome
to Coursera, do you
want to continue your
machine learning course?
MARIYA NAGORNA: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Sure,
here is your course.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE].
MARIYA NAGORNA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, demo gods.
All right, so let me jump in on
a quick recap of what we just
did.
We showed you how to
create actions.xml
and how to use built-in
intents to enable actions
in your Android app.
And then we showed
you how by doing
so your app can
now be discovered
across the many
surfaces on Android.
Now, we briefly glossed
over these, too,
but we had our colleagues
give a whole talk on how
to build app actions
two days ago,
and if you missed
it, don't worry,
please do go ahead and
watch the video on YouTube.
Now in the main
part of the demo,
we walked through how to claim
your actions on Google Project
so that you can enable your
actions to work on new devices.
And finally, we showed
you how to build and test
a simple companion app
that works great with audio
and video on a Smart Display.
Now, we certainly think
this is very cool.
We're very excited, and we tried
to make it really easy for you
so that a companion app like
this is just another interface
to your existing service.
Building experiences
that work on devices
which don't run Android
is not about bringing up
completely new
infrastructure from scratch.
It's more about just
extending your apps
to be more action centric and
more focused on connecting
with your users throughout
their day, wherever they are--
whether they're at home
or they're on the go.
So with that, let me
invite you to visit our web
page at actions.google.com
to learn more
about the concepts and the
tools that we covered today.
And we want to hear from
you, so please do sign up
at g.co/AppActions so that
you can give us feedback
on our built-in intent catalog.
And also by signing up,
you'll get notified when
app actions become available.
But most importantly, what
we encourage you today
is start thinking
about the experience
you can provide your users
for those times in their life
when their Android
device just might
be impractical or just
inconvenient to use
in that moment.
Take the next step today
and build companion actions
on devices that work for
the Google Assistant.
We want to thank
you for joining us.
And if you have any questions,
please come by our office hours
in the sandbox area.
Please enjoy the rest
of your time at I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]